Warner Brothers released the first
trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 a sequel
to 2017 standalone Wonder Woman movie
from DC Comics here's a breakdown of all
the characters in the trailer who they
are and what we know about them plus an
explanation of a few key Easter eggs as
one could infer from the title the film
takes place in the year 1984 and
introduces us to several characters we
haven't seen before let's start with the
most surprising reveal of the trailer
the reappearance of Chris Pines
character Steve Trevor the last time we
saw Steve was at the end of the original
Wonder Woman film when he sacrificed
himself detonating gas explosives on a
plane that he was piloting in order to
keep them out of the hands of the
Germans so it's quite startling to see
him in the trailer especially because he
appears not to have aged at all despite
the fact that roughly 70 years have
passed since the events of the first
film overall Steve Trevor's apparent
resurrection seems a bit fishy and there
are a couple of theories that's the
source of his reemergence one is that
the Steve Trevor we see in the trailer
is actually Martian Manhunter a member
of the Justice League with
shape-shifting powers while this theory
is possible we don't think it's as
likely as the second big theory about
Steve that his improbable return is due
to Wonder Woman being under some sort of
mind control from one of the movie's new
characters Maxwell Lord played by Pedro
Pascal in the comics Maxwell Lord is an
ambitious businessman that helped form
the Justice League International first
appearing in Justice League number one
from 1987 however it was slowly revealed
that Lord was actually villainous and
aspired to kill members of the Justice
League his ambitions became much more
realistic when he discovered that he had
extremely powerful mind-control
abilities this leads us back to what we
alluded to earlier about Steve Trevor's
reappearance possibly being a result of
Maxwell Lord putting Wonder Woman under
mind control in the trailer he says the
following lines think about finally
having everything you always wanted
now I take what I want in return so it
would seem that Diana is making some
sort of deal with Lord in order to get
Steve back
Lord might be just using his mind
control abilities to manipulate her the
other new character revealed in the
trailer is Barbara and Minerva played by
Kristen Wiig in the comics this
character is an archaeologist searching
for a fabled lost city after finding the
city and encountering the god of dwells
within Barbara Anne is transformed into
a deadly supervillain cheetah cheetah is
typically depicted as possessing
immensely enhanced strength and reflexes
she's an extremely formidable enemy
having been shown to have strength
comparable to Superman fast enough to
hit the flash and claws sharp enough to
pierce bulletproof skin
cheetahs fearsome powers might be one of
the reasons that we see Wonder Woman's
striking new outfit her golden eagle
armor in the comics the suit boosts
Wonder Woman's strength and durability
while also granting her the ability to
fly which seems to also be the case in
the new movie as were given a quick
glimpse of the suits wings the suit of
armor was first introduced in 1996 as
kingdom come issue number three it was
created in Wonder Woman's home of famous
Kira which is maybe why we get a couple
of glimpses of the island in the trailer
however these are most likely flashbacks
because Diana isn't allowed to return to
famous Kira and it seems that the shot
of the young girl running alongside
other Amazonians is in fact young Diana
in addition to the several exciting new
characters that were introduced in the
trailer there are also a couple of
Easter eggs to start off we have to talk
about that shot of Wonder Woman swinging
from lightning while the swinging is new
Wonder Woman has been depicted in the
comics as being able to ride lightning
canonically this ability makes sense
because she's the daughter of Zeus next
we have a callback to the watch that
Steve Trevor gave to Diana right before
he sacrificed himself in the original
movie the trailer shows that Diana has
kept his watch and a photo of him for
all the years that have passed since he
died in the trailer Steve reveals
himself to Diana by placing a new
digital watch in her hand symbolizing
his return there's also a photo at
Trevor's ranch
it seems that Diana likely visited
Steve's family the trailer also shows
Diana and Steve riding in a plane we
have a feeling it may be a sneak peek at
Wonder Woman's iconic and visit
jet Diana and Steve visit the famous
Hirshhorn Museum at the end of the
trailer in previous movies Diana works
as a museum curator so it would make
sense that Diana and archaeologist
Barbara Anne initially appear to be
friends politics seems to be an aspect
of the film as well as we see Wonder
Woman fighting assailants in the White
House the United States was involved in
the soviet-afghan war which was still
ongoing during 1984 and it looks like
part of the film will also take place in
Afghanistan
lastly we see a brief shot of a
satellite dish this could be a reference
to brother I a surveillance system
initially created by Batman to monitor
super human activity on earth at one
point in the comics Lord takes control
of the system the name comes from Big
Brother in George Orwell's classic novel
1984 making it all the more likely since
the movie is also set in 1984 was there
anything we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]
you